140 caractères l'espoir dans la
démocratie vous ça c'est un vrai
challenge pour paraphraser quelqu'un je
vais faire comme ça la démocratie c'est
la moins mauvaise des solutions
politiques il faut la préserver les
réseaux sociaux c'est une sorte de
caisse de résonance on vous apporte
systématiquement ce dont vous avez
besoin ce que l'algorithme et donc in
fine et les programmateurs ont pensé que
vous aviez besoin pour vous faire votre
opinion pour évoluer dans sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est cette espèce de
caisse de résonance qui pose d'ailleurs
des problèmes en terme de démocratie
c'est que à terme on ne voit plus que
des contenus qui sont conformes à ce
qu'on pense et donc ça renforce légende
dans la pensée qui l'on est donc dans la
consommation qui peuvent avoir et des
informations et des publicités donc
voilà il faut il faut qu'on arrive à
éduquer surtout la population et nos
concitoyens à ce que le numérique
raccourci c'est à dire le temps et donc
il faut qu'on leur apprenne que de temps
en temps il faut se poser et réfléchir à
une information avant de la rediffuser
re tweeter facebook et retour ce que
vous voulez sur les réseaux sociaux
quand on est démocrate on a quand même
tendance à prendre un peu de recul à se
poser à moins communiquer ou à
communiquer plus au fond sauf que les
réseaux sociaux twitter par exemple avec
le nombre de caractères qui l'a n'est
pas on n'est pas en capacité sur un
tweet d'exprimer le fond d'un
raisonnement les populistes ont tendance
à donner les informations à sur réagir
sur les informations et donc c'est
exactement ce que les réseaux sociaux m
plusieurs clics plus il ya d'audience
puis à l'audience plusieurs cliques et
c'est un cercle vicieux où vertueux en
fonction de l'endroit où l'on se place
c'est là où on a besoin d'avoir des
médias et des journalistes indépendants
qui sont en capacité de prendre le recul
suffisant pour démonter les fausses
informations et y apporter les
véritables les véritables nouvelles